well we know that the premises
priorities are to have inflation clearly
food inflation is an element of that but
bringing together the food sector today
whether it's from retailers people from
Hospitality people who grow food the
processing it's all been an important
part of a discussion on what it is that
we can do to make sure that we get on
with Farmers producing the best British
food possible we've discussed about
regulation too so all of these elements
is part of a constructive discussion is
there anything that came out of today in
terms of like firm decisions that will
help to bring down we made the
significant number of announcements
today about a variety of Investments
about what we're doing to help with
exports around the world all those sorts
of things help improve the profitability
for farmers in order to make sure that
we continue to also have that
sustainable food production here but
we'll keep working together through the
food and drink sector Council in order
to keep some of the reflections from
today on how we can make General
improvements families are obviously
struggling hugely with the basics at the
moment is the government going to do
more to help families right now
obviously you know food prices might
come down in time but for the next six
months it doesn't look like this well
people are working very hard to try and
make sure that we have an affordable
sustainable resilient food supply chain
and how that helps with customers but of
course the government is supporting
people on the lowest income with the
household support fund payments have
been going out to people in order to
help with that particular cost of living
challenge but more broadly of course
we're seeing changes to energy cost
scene then start to come down that's
critical for the food industry as well
some MPS are investigating some of the
supermarkets and wondering whether there
might be some profiteering going on in
the supermarkets are you worried that
Supermarket profits are too high I'm
conscious that our supermarkets get
involved in a variety of ways on how
they help their consumers I'll leave
that to the select committee but what is
critical is coming here today getting
the food supply chain from the Farm
indeed the the sea right through to the
fork and about how we can continue to
work together to have that security of
food production but also making sure we
are have a resilient one and
unaffordable food production as well and
that's critical today